in all competitive games a meta game
develops and usually with it a mutual
understanding between players that not
all characters are created equal however
in today's gaming age developers are
able to tweak metas by buffing and
nerfing characters through patches to
make them more balanced or viable and in
many instances it works but occasionally
it doesn't and some characters never
truly find their place in competitive
play in fact some of them become the
targets of ridicule they become memes
meme characters are mechanically broken
community driven jokes typically
selected only in poor taste but the joke
is usually inconsequential and destined
to fade into obscurity in Rainbow six
siege one such character has refused to
accept this fate and ironically through
his perceived uselessness has risen as a
wildly popular cult figure within the
games community his name is Alexander
tachanka cinavia and to many he is the
Lord to Chong cos tale is a complex one
it's the bittersweet story of a
character who doesn't fit into his own
game and a community that embraced him
because of it I love him why do you love
him
because of the meme it's also the story
of a passionate and dedicated
development team struggling to correct
their greatest mistake without upsetting
a fanbase who gave it a life of its own
but before we get into that let's answer
the question who is the Lord tachanka
is a release defense operator whose name
references Russia's world war one
horse-drawn machine gun carriages which
like many aspects of Russian life had
their own song
[Music]
while tachanka might be heavily armored
he lacks the mobility of his
twentieth-century namesake and is one of
the slowest operators in siege and
although his primary and secondary
weapons are actually half decent the
main source for his ridicule lies in his
special ability LMG mounted and loaded
that's right
Tatanka can set up a mounted drum fed
LMG capable of tearing through drywall
just as easily as his opponents now in
theory this might sound pretty [ __ ]
badass
but in practice not so much now I'm
saying that there's something wrong to
Shanklin there's something wrong with
the problem is that Rainbow six siege is
about movement and information and
because almost all surfaces can be
destroyed or penetrated by gunfire
standing still in the open is a recipe
for being made into Swiss cheese
unfortunately for tachanka his turret
simply doesn't have a great place in the
game it takes forever to set up and take
down your movement is limited while
using it and you can't set it up too
close to cover because the weapon needs
room to be maneuver in fact tachanka x'
overall kit is ranked so lowly by
players that many even think recruit the
default operator selected if you fail to
pick another is considered a more viable
pick because he offers more in-game
utility all of these factors combine to
make tachanka one of the least picked
and effective operators in siege and
only a few months after the game's
release
he had become known as one of its worst
operators it was really difficult for us
because it was like a it's how to say
that it's like when because we didn't
make that many mistakes in fact when we
were
and veteran Canyon is one of them if you
look at how many operator we added again
I mean it's not that one of the
alternate actually it doesn't really
play how we saw the game will be playing
but it's this one mistake
it's flub in our face every day on every
front but Ubisoft mistake had developed
an underdog status and over time a
strange Fame tachanka had ascended from
being a mere mortal to Lord Tatanka
seemingly the first time someone called
him Lord to chunka was youtuber
microwave gaming I'm also looking for
more clips for a kill of the week
montage by you the viewers if you would
like to participate then drop me a link
or send me a video if you have an ace
with the Tatanka the chances are you're
gonna be number one because all hail
Lord chunka and the basis of the Lord to
chunk a meme is that he's so bad he's
actually incredible people love him in
the same way that they love watching the
room 4th of July
hot dog eating contests you're
witnessing greatness athletic mastery
this is not a parlor trick this is not
sleight of hand
this is Major League Eating best ever
and Star Wars it's a trap wait a second
did you add this I would never agree to
this anyway in an attempt to make
Tatanka more balanced Ubisoft introduced
changes later in the year during the
mid-season reinforcements for Operation
Red crow the adjustments included a
bulletproof shield for his turret and
some additional recoil to the gun itself
and it was in this update that Ubisoft
began leaning into the community's love
for the Lord to Chong kameen highlighted
by the inscription of the Russian word
for Lord on his new turret shield and a
special appearance by his voice actor
Anatoly zenovia on the reveal stream
want to say what's up to the chat -
there that's that's really awesome yes
your eyes do not deceive you the Lord
even has a fan created emote which you
will see spammed in
which in the end the changes brought by
Operation Red Crow did little to make
tachanka more effective and even today
his pic rate remains quite low but in
spite of this his Ameen God status has
continued to be supported by Ubisoft who
in May of this year released an actual
Lord to chunk a bundle and at the six
major in Paris sieges eSports director
Alexandre Remy explained to us why you
be soft chose to embrace the Lord me
overall and not really talking about
that same time what he's been singing in
I'd say between energy and beginning of
your dream is that the operator as
characters as personalities are starting
to grow in terms of popularity we see
more and more whether it's fun art or
means or whatever you name it people
that are taking a savanna all of the
operators the one that they relate the
most to and and put them on as knees and
icons attached some job was clearly the
first one so there's no particular
ambition for us to really push that
Chunkin but yes to push all of the
universe and all of the characters while
most interaction with the tachanka meme
happens outside of the game the Lord
does make the occasional ranked
appearance just with questionable
motivations it's only for when you're
beating someone like three oh and you
just want to rub it in but you're better
than them that's all that's all he is
like you've got a spawn peak on its own
it's an embarrassment and if you can if
you get a peak - that's already died and
spawn that's bad you know when you're
playing a game as well and someone uses
it you don't get angry
you saw her laugh and you just go along
with it and it's absolutely if one's not
sick it's great even though tachanka is
often used for in-game trolling his
current state as a broken but beloved
operator
presents a complicated issue for Ubisoft
we session camera institution where we
counts chibs it - it's for shows - it
doesn't belong to such doesn't work -
stay static you know
sit by it's all about you know playing
you whole new line of sight so if we
remove the turret is it still touching
guys when I'm in Java for fantasy in
Germany but it's it so it's beyond so
gameplay maybe like two years ago before
the government then you will have just
remove the tool at something else no one
will have Emma Sarah but now this so
much involved around in a key it's
touching like it's touching and therein
lies the problem how do you change the
character without completely destroying
his community-created identity we asked
siege fans and personalities how they'd
react to a significant to chunk of
rework and their answers only
highlighted the division I'll probably
be very unhappy because you know you
just can't change a meme like that like
if they try to make it more competitive
leave I'll blow to remove the mean
completely so probably beyond that BA I
think it's good for the community to
have something like you know it's not a
lot of t-shirts it's the banter of the
community I don't think they should
touch him I'd love it because he needs
he needs a complete rework as soon as
they gave other operators moveable LMGs
he became irrelevant I have no idea what
that change would be like I think a
plausible change would be that his
turret can shoot through shields and
that would actually be like legitimate
so then you would have a direct
deterrent against the shield pushing
site because you have a turret that can
actually shoot through that kind of
stuff so that would be that'd be really
good so the question then becomes what's
more important having another viable
operator in your games meta or leaving a
community born meme undisturbed
it's a puzzle that Ubisoft is still
trying to solve
no no scenario where we just let him
like that forever we need to address
this issue how to address it
regardless of where you stand on more to
chunka whether you think he's a dying
meme or he sieges patron saint whether
you think he should be buffed or just
left alone he elicits a reaction and his
presence in the game has not only
contributed to the formation of CJ's
unique communal identity but it has also
further informed Ubisoft design choices
behind operators going forward dodging
case it's a great distance that we know
like spective gameplay doesn't work in
cities you have to do more than that you
have to bring more than set so we
learned from the listen from the
feedback that we have on attendee so
Peralta what they like was they disliked
him that's one of the things that makes
you that makes the difference between a
success and the flop is that how much
you learn from your mistake it's okay to
make mistake that you have to
acknowledge that request mistake you
don't from that and move on
so there you have it Lord to chaka proof
that a meme is capable of positively
shaping both the community's identity
and the development philosophy behind
one of eSports most exciting rising
games sounds like more of a miracle than
a mistake right you know man I always
think they were doing the Lord's work
with this show exploiting means that
normies hey man the Lord loves all
equally told you that he did that junka
will always stand by you what the [ __ ]
how do you feel when people pick him
instead of you I mean there are people
people are doing a lot of mistakes a lot
of stupid things I don't know what to
say about this kind of people choosing
to chunker and stead of Blackbeard I
mean it's it's a sort of insane
what would you say to all those people
who are proclaiming the lordship of
Tatanka you guys are wrong and I will
come for you